imagine a world where we can communicate
with machines using not only words but
also images
visual chat GPT combines the
conversational abilities of chat GPT
with the visual understanding and
generation abilities of visual
Foundation models picture this you
upload an image of a yellow flower and
you ask visual chat GPT to generate a
red flower conditioned on the predicted
depth of this image and then make it
like a cartoon with its prompt manager
visual chat GPT can start a chain of
execution involving different visual
Foundation models to detect depth
information generate an image of a red
flower with this depth information and
then change its style into a cartoon its
ability to combine language and visual
processing opens up many exciting
possibilities for human machine
interaction it's not just about what we
say it's about what we see